What's the alternative given that they
have a point,
while as far as I can tell,
the alternative is a proper return to
the past and that is precisely to
journey into the chaos,
to look at the worst possible thing and
to pull the dead father up from the
chaotic depths.
That's how you stop being a puppet.
Someone whose strings are being pulled
by forces they do not understand behind
the scenes,
you find out what's great about your
culture,
this thing that's provided us with
everything that we see in this room,
this amazing warmth that we're
experiencing when it's 30 bloody below,
outside the fact that the electricity of
the heart and the computational
resources are working and that we can
all sit here peacefully and then no one
is hungry fat.
We're too fat.
That's our big problem.
Oh No,
we have so much stuff.
We're getting fat.
Yeah,
well that's a good problem to have.
We should have some gratitude for what's
being produced that's brought us to this
point and we need to wake up and
understand what we're doing.
Well,
that's what.
That's what people like.
That's what the psychoanalysts were
trying to do in the 20th century.
That's what all the great clinicians
we're trying to do and I would say above
all else that was what Carl young was
trying to do.
He believed firmly that the idea of the
divine spark within the individual was
a,
was a metaphysical reality by which he
meant a reality that actually
transcended and existed superordinate to
the physical reality of more real
reality.
That's whatever consciousness is
something we understand from a
scientific perspective,
not at all that's been represented in
our mythologies as far back as we can
push them as an independent agent in the
world,
giving rise to form.
That's how we treat each other.
That's how we recognize ourselves.
That's how we judge each other.
You make your bed and then you lie in it
and everyone knows it and that's not to
say that you're not subject to random
and chaotic circumstances and the
tragedy of life.
Just because you can do some things
doesn't mean you can do everything,
but you can do some things and if you
don't do them,
then things fall apart and the problem
with things falling apart is that you
will be happy about it to the degree
that you're not trying to repair them
because to the degree that you do not
manifest what's within you,
then your life falls apart around you
and everything that could make you
bitter multiplies until you're in a
situation where you want the destruction
you want to bring it on,
and it's not surprising.
[inaudible] life can be so terrible that
the question of whether or not it should
exist at all can be a real question,
but the answer to that is his life so
terrible that it shouldn't exist.
Well,
the answer is it depends on how you live
it and if your life is so terrible that
you can't bear it,
then it raises the question of whether
or not you're living at properly.
And that's not to say that people don't
suffer under burdens that are too great
for them to bear.
They certainly do.
It doesn't matter because if you let
that embitter you,
if you let that destroy your allegiance
to the proper path,
all it does is make that worse and
everything else.
It's no out.